hello and welcome to PlayStation great
today I'd like to start a new series
based around the people behind the
characters we see and hear in videogames
every so often there's a character you
think I've heard that voice before well
in this series we will look into what
they've done in the past so episode 1
series 1 Borderlands 3 let's do this
let's start with the vault hunters which
did you choose on your first playthrough
was it the Beastmaster flack well did
you know that the voice actor behind his
dulcet tones is none other than some
Wang Chao most humans are frail and weak
but you've got admirable heft girl
better known as pros that day or pro ZD
depending on where you are in the world
he blew up on vine and now you can find
him on YouTube my vault hunter of choice
is Zane Flint played by Qian Barry worst
thing that ever happened to me
let's do it again ian has a long career
in TV and film and a few video games -
including voicing in black panther in
Lego Marvel superheroes to desire Black
Panther ruler of Wakanda and Mara the
siren is played by Zahra Faizal I've
likely butchered that name
surely you know who I am the tiger of
portal II crime fighter
warrior for peace its Amara Zahra has
done so much in her acting career
including voice work in titanfall 2
league of legends and crackdown 3 but
get this if you've played apex legends
you hear her voice every single game
Zahra is the voice of the announcer
introducing your champion round 1
beginning countdown you are the apex
champions our final vault hunter is Mo's
the gunner played by Marisa cilenti well
my old squad is all dead and flat off
thinks I am too so it's just me and iron
bear mech repairs aren't cheap and I
heard there's treasure in the vaults
seemed like the right call Marissa has
over 20 years experience she has also
voiced many characters in live-action
films such
attack on titan pretty damn cool once
again Ashly Burch returns to voice tiny
Tina complete with her wandering eye how
many lives we snuffed out removing all
hope for redemption condemning our
victims to eternal judgment because of
our petty whims and desire for loot and
glory
me neither [ __ ] Ashley place so many
characters you know such as Chloe in
life is strange Cassie cage in Mortal
Kombat X and fortnight lovers
Ashley voices ray in save the world so
introductions
I'm ray and we are the commander's
support crew Marley would be also she
plays chun-li in Street Fighter nebula
in guardians of the galaxy and Cassie
Rose in Minecraft story mode this girl
is unstoppable it doesn't prove anything
Lucas is still way guilty are looking
oh gee heroes lilith and Tanis are
played by the same voice actor Coleen
clickin beard okay that name is slightly
amusing but definitely stands out
clickin beard nice Colleen is a behemoth
of voice acting appearing in Dragon Ball
Z Full Metal Alchemist and danganronpa 3
yes do you have a query is this a poor
attempt at flirtation or have you gone
blind in bold lines 3 we meet a computer
AI which we put into a teddy bear you
can't write this stuff this is Bale x
Bale X is played by the rapper TV and
movie star ice-t Wow
I checked out his IMDB page and he is so
prolific he starred in movies alongside
Keanu Reeves he's had huge album
releases and get this he was in grand
theft auto san andreas he played mad dog
some fake-ass gangster rapper [ __ ]
licorice Marley's friend
a returning character in bought lunch
three is none other than iridium Harding
crazy Earl but did you know he's played
by Randy Pitchford what you out pick
something I got all day but not for you
you cannot go on a dog you want a day a
prize or something the chief executive
officer of gearbox software ie the
driving force behind the franchise and
the guy who presents Portland's content
on stage I would never have guessed
crazy Earl was Randy would you scag
liquor another returning character
everyone recognizes is the unmistakable
voice of claptrap but this time it
sounds slightly different you can just
call me
former gearbox VP of strategic
partnerships voice the original
character for the last ten years but now
after a very public bust up with crazy L
I mean Randy Pitchford
he has been replaced by Jim firaga
there's a Brit in the cast of
Borderlands 3 Lorelai who swears so much
it's like being back in London passwords
open the bloody door before I shove a
coffee grinder up your arse Kieren
strange place her Kieren is actually a
singer rather than a voice actor so it's
pretty new to this but judging by his
voice he'll be picking up roles
regularly it's a cover
Vaughn is another character introduced
in tales from the borderlands his voice
sounds so familiar to me and if you're
Walking Dead fan you may know him I
warned him not to mess with that crap
but what do they do they tie me up and
they take it to the Calypso twins not
cool bro he's played by Chris Hardwick
who also presents the TV show the
talking dead and so many others he
founded Nerdist by the way and has been
on so many TV shows it would take an
hour to go through them can't let him
know you're afraid and totally
defenseless bro bandit life next up is
Maya the siren guardian Maya is played
by Martha Homs
wrecking face on a thenis and taking the
fight to mallow on on an asteroid death
laser you're two for two in my book
fault hunter I recognize her voice from
the free-to-play game paladins she
voices kanessa there but her biggest wow
job must be her work in the Pokemon
universe playing Maya and officer Jenny
back atcha a perfect fit man or woman
young or old my sights are steady and my
trigger cold so you're probably here for
this next character mad Moxxi it's
always happy hour when I see you sugar
space is cold honey let's get you warmed
up Moxie is portrayed by Brianna
Valencia who's been voice acting since
1986 when she was only two years old you
can hear a voice in everything World of
Warcraft duke nukem hearthstone do a
battle on The Walking Dead Dragon Ball
super and so many more oh and captain
Briggs in the division to shoot him in
the dick
that's the drift another celebrity cameo
comes in the shape of dastardly duo pain
and terror I'm sure you know who voices
them none other than Penn & Teller
likely cast due to Randy Pitchford
obsession with magic and who else better
than Penn & Teller teller is
particularly good his voice acting is
the greatest I've ever heard and to
finish let's look at the villains of the
piece troy calypso played by max
Mittleman
max has been in everything you can
imagine in the videogame world he's been
in Wow
spider-man Pokemon die have blow he
played Zeke in fallout 4 and most
recently he's the new lion-o in the
Thundercats reboot the queen of evil in
Borderlands 3 is tyreme calypso played
by ELISA Melendez well I've taken your
powers you might as well finish you off
ELISA is extremely new to video game
voice acting and regards her singing
career as her priority she's part of a
youtube channel called film joy which
looks in depth at the film's you love
judging by this performance she'll be
around for many years to come and just
before we go let's just look at some of
the really random things that the NPC
say in this game they are so ridiculous
sometimes see for yourself what a moment
I thought my head was destined to be
displayed above some bandits mantle
between a pornographic magazine and well
another pornographic magazine most
likely volt hunter I'm so glad you're
here because now I can challenge you to
a freestyle rap battle
so you want to hear a story huh well too
bad
this is Marcus time there best things in
life are free because then you can sell
them for a huge markup so there we have
it meet the voice actors of borderlands
3 there are over 50 actors named in the
credits so this was only a snippet if
I've missed your favorite character let
me know in the comments and I'll make a
part 2 thanks for your time and thank
you so much for letting me try something
different on the channel I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade been a pleasure see
you soon
[Applause]
[Music]